well i want your take on this metro is
asking this question
is it curtains um for the voicemail
now i'm excited to hear your guys's
feelings and thoughts about this because
it's no secret that people are now
texters rather than voicemailers and one
study found 75 percent of millennials
will avoid phone calls at all costs
funny how a ring used to be like ooh and
now it's like
um voicemail haters say they are too
long take up too much time just send me
a text while voicemail lovers say
they're more personal and you can
actually hear the tone of the voice of
the person on the other end which you
don't get in the text but by the way
they're also leaving out the fact that
now voice memos on text are like all the
rage especially in the dating world
really oh yeah it's hansel it's so hot
right now so you would rather text
somebody that you're you'd rather voice
text someone you're dating how you can
do it
who knows about this new phenomenon of
voice texting yeah the kids know these
people know and i think the reason
people also love it is the phenomenon is
doesn't it disappear in 24 hours as well
so you can you can say what you want to
say
it's just a little floating treat that
won't last too long well you know i
don't even call people anymore without
texting first you know what i mean i
text like can you talk and then i call
because and i i feel like who who just
picks up the phone and calls somebody
anymore that's like what our forefathers
did you just like don't yeah it's you
know i i just i like the little heads up
but
who wants voicemail to just go away
it is funny and i do believe because of
the proximity we've never been this
close even though we're so far when
people
ring you up facetime you text you call
you it's in your hand so i think there's
like a physical whoa
yeah like it's not your phone on the
wall and it's not a letter you're
opening like we are literally living in
the day and age where like it feels like
a whoa moment yeah you know it's a
psychology i just it just reminded me
when you're talking it's like do you
remember when the phone used to ring in
the house the landline and then you
would be in your bedroom be like who's
it for like someone else would answer it
and then wait wait and they'd be like
ross phone's for you
and it'll be so exciting the phone's for
me i'm gonna go downstairs and who's it
going to be and hello
oh that was fun i also um kind of missed
like emergency breakthroughs on the
phone remember that so old school i know
they were terrifying but exciting at the
same time yeah if i called my friend and
it was busy you could call the operator
and be like i have to get through and
they'd be like excuse me an emergency
call from ross and then ross what's
wrong i'd be like nothing what are you
doing
[Music]
um okay well guess what we're more
connected than ever and um it's just
nice to know that somebody really even
wants to contact you why don't we just
take it as a win and call it a day i'll
take that
i'll take that
[Music]
you